I'm sorry Swimming with Sharks on the
yacht why would I get in the water oh my
gosh
Leah are you good because last night was
strange no I actually am glad you just
brought that up yeah because I want to
ask Porsha something when you said do
you want to be here and also because
yesterday Giselle you were like so are
you okay being here yeah and I think you
said it because when we were opening up
at lunch I said I wanted like be honest
with you guys I had I I was I was I've
had feelings about maybe I didn't want
to come here I said that at night I
really had hesitation coming here
because last season was so
hard for me so I thought it was like
kind of shady for you to then bring up
something that I was open about and
being very vulnerable about that I
didn't even want to admit put away I'm
sorry yeah so wait Leah you want to know
why she said why do you want to go home
you want to know why I made a joke just
now about you going home no wait you've
been acting like you want to go home
girl you are wild girl you are wild as
hell you're like confronting someone
about your lives what last night you
were saying that you were so bored I was
bored last night so you say to the whole
damn table why don't y'all get drunk or
something I'm bored can you guys like
get drunk or something Leah says she's
bored oh why don't you guys like order
like when you're drunk monkeys or
something like oh we're not entertaining
unless we're drunk right exactly what
you want is that it we're not
entertaining exactly that's what I'm
used to people saying to me because
before this trip even started Marisol
texted me being like I really respect
you for not drinking blah blah
but I wish you were still drinking so I
felt a type of way and maybe I should
have talked to you about it but I didn't
want to bring that into the trip listen
to me you live in a real world people
are going to tell you that kind of stuff
like oh like you know you should be like
nobody tells me that but like as a joke
why does everyone want me to drink I
don't get it like you're the one that
told me if you don't have a drink in
four hours in the morning your stomach
starts to hurt like I don't want to
drink I never said that now you're
making it up you said that Marisol it's
like can we just wait till like noon to
drink the Vodka what does that mean is
there like a schedule have some eggs
have a bowl of cereal morning noon at
night that's the schedule as I parch I
drink I think that with a drink that's
not a lie here
the victim again really that is so
clever Leah
[Music]
thank you
because we're on the ocean you gotta see
it
I'm gonna take a little walk just to
gather my thoughts I'm gonna go upstairs
for a minute don't let them work no I'm
not I'm not I have to pee okay I have to
pee okay
thank you
[Music]